qual é a hora de tirar o sonho da gaveta
e colocá lo em prática
eu não sei de vocês onde estava no terek
do ano passado mas eu estava no
backstage operando os projetores para
que os demais spikes compartilhar essa
história deles com o resto da platéia o
que aconteceu em um ano que chamou tanto
a atenção da organização a ponto de me
tirar lá de trás me colocar aqui em cima
é que pela primeira vez eu tive uma
ideia e acreditei nela com todas as
minhas forças
a idéia foi essa foi uma que
provavelmente muitos de vocês que estão
me ouvindo aqui já tiverem algum momento
de viajar pelo mundo
eu não lembro quando eu tive essa ideia
mas eu sei que eu estava em casa vendo
um programa que mostrava imagens de
drone de países da américa do sul que
teve uma epifania
esse cara eu também posso conhecer a
américa do sul de carro e foi aí que eu
comecei a lapidar essa essa idéia por
mais louca que ela pudesse parecer
afinal de contas eu teria que deixar
para trás trabalho família e amigos
em nenhum momento meu cérebro ficou
pensando no que eu perderia mas sim no
que eu ganhar ia especialmente
experiência de vida e isso fez toda a
diferença
e cá pra nós se viajar por si só já é
muito bom viajar em boa companhia seria
surreal
ele estava muito forte
estava animado café
ele fez a seguinte pergunta vamos rodar
américa do sul de carro
eu confesso para vocês eu achei que ele
estava brincando que era uma piada mas
não era mesmo verdade
uma das coisas que eu sempre pensei
comigo quando o tempo passar e eu olhar
pra trás
eu queria fazer algo com que eu pudesse
me orgulhar
eu queria olhar pra trás e dizer uau eu
fiz isso uma das coisas que eu sempre
quis fazer era viajar e conhecer um dos
países
mas eu nunca me foquei para que isso
realmente acontecer quando crise me fez
essa pergunta quando ele me fez uma
proposta eu não hesitei
eu achei a oportunidade perfeita e eu
aceitei na mesma hora
bt ideia não foi o problema afinal de
contas ela veio naturalmente até mim mas
a partir do momento que a gente sabia o
que queria fazer a gente tinha que fazer
por onde e teve muito trabalho árduo por
trás de tudo isso a primeira coisa que a
gente precisou foi pesquisar
eu nunca tinha viajado para tão longe
que está para outros países
então a gente teve que pesquisar muitas
coisas na internet eu li alguns livros e
tentei contato com muitas pessoas que já
tinham viajado para outros lugares para
tentar me absorver o máximo de
informações possíveis para ser o mais
assertivo possível
foi nessa época da pesquisa que eu
identifiquei que o maior gasto que a
gente teria seria com combustível e aí
surgiu o primeiro grande problema com
que carro que a gente vai viajar
a gente já tinha pontuado várias coisas
analisadas algumas opções mas nenhuma
tinha batido de verdade
eis que um dia viver chega em casa
dizendo crise eu pesquisei na internet
vi que vários casais estão fazendo uma
viagem de kombi porque a gente não
compra uma kombi faz isso também
combinam da kombi gastar muito se o
nosso gasto principal vai ser com
gasolina porque a viajar de kombi já
vamos começar errado
além do que com bié carro de trabalho
carro de empreiteira de transporte de
alunos de escola que publica a obra é
difícil achar uma boa e barata e outra
coisa kombi não tem segurança
se a gente vier sofreu um acidente a
minha perna vai ser o para choque sem
chance a gente não vai de kombi esquece
lá em casa como quem manda sou eu um mês
depois a adquirir foi integrado ao time
passada essa parte da pesquisa a gente
começou com o planejamento o que seria
feito e quando seria feito nós montamos
algumas planilhas e colocamos em um
cronograma tudo o que a gente faria pra
não se esticar demais nessa parte de
preparação depois
uma parte da ação que como o próprio
nome já diz foi a hora de colocar a mão
na massa
nessa fase a gente começou a preparar
tudo que a gente por dia por conta
própria
aquilo que a gente não podia agente
contratava algum profissional para nos
ajudar e até uma pergunta que
provavelmente muitos se fazem enquanto
que vocês gastaram para montar kombi
para mostrar de uma maneira bem sucinta
aqui tem esses dois gráficos ea gente
chegou perto dos 50 mil reais incluindo
a compra da kombi toda parte da
manutenção e o acabamento interno
então é claro que a gente não tinha essa
grana e foi nesse momento do projeto que
a gente descobriu que a gente precisava
de mais dinheiro
depois de todo o planejamento e
preparação da kombi
precisávamos agora é arrumar dinheiro de
bom viajar não é nada barato né
e pra nós não foi diferente precisávamos
arrumar o máximo de dinheiro possível
para realmente fazer a expedição
acontecer
decidimos várias coisas dentre elas
economizar nada de pizza de final de
semana e pouquinho no cinema o foco era
o projeto nós também vendemos muitas
coisas coisas de dentro de casa coisas
pessoais
eu vendi tudo nas redes sociais foi bem
interessante nessa época que algumas
pessoas chegaram a me perguntar vive o
que está acontecendo e estão vendendo
tudo e assim entende praticamente tudo
nós também fizemos alguns produtos como
as camisetas que estamos investidos aqui
outros produtos também e muitas muitas
pessoas nos ajudaram
muitas pessoas abraçaram a causa e nós
conseguimos levantar um dinheiro
mas ainda não era o suficiente
foi aí que decidimos pixelizada lataria
da kombi fazendo dela um outdoor
ambulante cada quadrado podia ser
adesivado por quem quisesse e querem
saber deu muito certo muito certo a
gente conseguir o dinheiro necessário
dinheiro suficiente
muitas pessoas nos ajudaram graças a
deus é bom
ela estava pronta nós já tínhamos o
dinheiro suficiente agora só faltava uma
coisa
a data da despedida essa data ficou
marcada para o dia 22 de julho de 2018
e esse dia foi muito muito especial para
nós
a lei muitas pessoas nesse dia foram
vamos dar um abraço para nos desejar boa
sorte e também compartilhar um momento
que de certa maneira de certa forma é um
delas também
afinal a gente não fez nada sozinhos
esse dia realmente foi muito muito
especial teve choro teve abraços mas
também teve muita muita alegria
bom depois de toda despedida
nós entramos na kombi e agora era real
o mundo seria o nosso quintal
eu sou o tipo de cara que acredita que
uma imagem vale mais do que mil palavras
e pra que vocês sintam um pouco do que a
gente viu nos últimos meses
basta olhar essa imagem aqui que ela
fala bastante do que a gente fez por
onde
durante todo esse tempo que a gente
rodou durante todo aquele tempo que a
gente se olhou e viu que agora era real
a gente começou então a acreditar que
era possível fazer todas essas marcas
que nós deixamos no mapa também deixaram
marcas em nós e nos engrandeceram muito
sintetizar tudo que a gente viveu nesses
dias e todos esses lugares que a gente
passou é complicado mas se eu pudesse
tirar cinco grande cinco grandes lições
de tudo isso que a gente viveu seriam
essas
a primeira foi a questão da adaptação
embora pareça que tudo eram flores por
causa que a gente gostava coisas legais
nas redes sociais não era bem assim
pra que vocês têm a ideia estava
viajando de kombi em dois adultos
o nosso espaço era um pouco menor do que
esse tapete aqui então a gente teve que
abandonar de vez o conforto coisas que
todo mundo tem em casa a qualquer
momento como água corrente e energia pra
sempre questão de banheiro de chuveiro
com água quente e até mesmo a wifi
aí a gente já não tinha sempre então
isso nos ensinou uma importante lição a
de dar valor ea de racionar a segunda
grande lição é a questão da comunicação
erroneamente a gente pensou que pelo
português é parecido com o espanhol a
gente chegar lá falando com os hermanos
tranquilamente
não foi bem assim a partir do momento
que a gente cruzou com o uruguai
a gente se deu conta que as províncias e
os departamentos têm o dialeto tenha
gírias e tem a velocidade de fala como a
gente tem aqui no norte e no sul e em
outros todos os lugares então a gente
teve que correr bastante atrás pra não
ficar à mercê nessa questão de
comunicação
esse ponto negativo acabou se tornando
um ponto positivo porque foi em virtude
dessa dificuldade de comunicação que
muita gente se sensibilizou com nos
connosco e começaram a ajudar os
viajantes de kombi
então a gente criou muitas amizades com
pessoas de diferentes culturas costumes
e valores
o melhor de tudo dessas amizades é o
desinteresse das pessoas
ninguém queria saber o meu sobrenome a
minha profissão a minha linhagem a minha
descendência as pessoas se do avaí só
queria saber um pouco da nossa história
e agente em troca compartilhada e pediu
mesmo a gente conheceu gente do mundo
inteiro viajando de todos os tipos e
seguramente a gente vai levar muitos
desses amigos no peito para o resto da
vida
a quarta missão é um pouco pesada mas
ela tem que ser falada que a questão da
desintoxicação a gente não percebia o
quanto a gente estava na pressão do dia
a dia enquanto aqui a gente estava com
estresse do trabalho com a questão das
notícias que chegam pelos noticiários e
até mesmo por ficar olhando a grama do
vizinho pelas redes sociais
achando que os outros sim é que tem a
vida boa plena e feliz
a partir do momento que a gente deixou
mundano de lado e começou a olhar pra
dentro é que a viagem fez mais sentido
a gente começou a observar o
sobrenatural o divino e aí sim eu me
sentir livre pela primeira vez
a última grande lição a questão da não
tem como não falar um pouco clichê mas
são os discos
pegar gelo pela primeira vez pisar nas
areias do deserto do atacama olhar um
vulcão de perto ou tomar água do rio na
carretera austral tocar um pingüim ver
uma oca as baleias nadando ali na orla
da praia todas essas coisas fizeram
todos os nossos trabalhos dados valer
muito a pena de forma que toda essa
experiência e essa vivência que a gente
teve com certeza vai coroar e 4a sempre
no resto das nossas vidas
e hoje o que a gente pode trazer aqui
pra vocês é que acreditem que é possível
fazer a gente procurasse nou muito os
nossos sonhos esperando que alguma coisa
incrível acontecesse mas não existe
condições perfeitas para que algo
aconteça a gente acreditou num sonho
acreditou no que a gente podia fazer ea
gente achou os meios e as pessoas que
nos ajudaram a fazer tudo isso se tornar
possível de modo que se as nossas
palavras não possam motivá-los quem sabe
um pouco do que a gente viveu pode
ilustrar melhor deus me deu a mão me deu
você eu aprender causados e medita nosso
amor
eu quase morri de saudade enquanto não
me diga que o pai e ele lhe a vontade de
ser meu filho ninguém meu coração e
mathew outra mim e eu quero me apaixonar
poderá gostar eu li chenney e eu
encontro do jeito que deus te lá
eu você ia assitir eu aprender
a ser vendida no amor i do jeito que eu
te amo nem prova contra ele ama o bordão
que não se repita é forte nossa aliança
com a criança o pai me fez te ei a forma
como ele enxerga sorrir enquanto te
carrega dizendo que é de seca
enquanto você descansa gravou ele essa
lembrança eu saber como fazer eu quero
me apaixono da tone dia até morrer só de
encostar eu lhe ser feito
eu vou conversar até morrer e quem sabe
eu encontro jeito que eu deixe essa
canção a todos os filhos pais mães
filhos e filhas que vai rolar o melhor
lugar
o senhor é o mar ao redor que protege
suas filhas mulher e curiosa quem achar
a seu valor é sede de muitos clubes é
mais que o piso é mais que eu sonhei eu
sei eu sou mais que fez que enquanto a
mulher enquanto o tesouro onde está o
tesouro está no meu coração ea
inspiração para ser o melhor que pudesse
é o melhor pra você deixará o homem sua
casa se unir à sua mulher e juntos será
uma só carne mais alto dos lucros mais
fundo dos olhos o que deus uniu o homem
não se pai
[Música]
ela vendeu amor me de você
a quadrilha usava sem medida
nosso amor é teu amor de deus você
[Música]
aprender medina transformou essa nossa
expedição ela não foi só uma viagem de
convite
ela foi uma viagem interior também nos
fez acreditar em nós mesmos nos fez
acreditar que é possível realizar muita
coisa
quando nós chegamos no brasil e até
mesmo na durante a expedição algumas
pessoas comentaram o seguinte com a
gente como vocês são corajosos isso
muito corajosos mas não é só a coragem
nós acreditamos que seria possível nós
realmente acreditamos que seria possível
e nos focamos porque a expedição
realmente acontecesse
bom depois dessa aventura incrível
você deve estar se perguntando e aí mas
não vão continuar a expedição acabou
a gente vai continuar mas agora a gente
a gente vai dar um tempo a gente quer
fazer algumas adaptações na kombi alguns
ajustes até porque a kombi só tem lugar
para duas pessoas ea gente vai precisar
de mais um lugar que nós estamos grave
[Aplausos]